come on
oh he turned into meat chunks are boys
back oh yeah look at this guy healing
his way in to save the day
it's so weird how it's DG cloth I mean
it kind of works I only realized it was
CG cloth had a few shots in
there's literally people there this is
not fun anymore it's going a little too
far into the cartoon realm really
yeah
thanks to PayPal honey for sponsoring
this video
hi everybody I'm Jordan and before we
get into our amazing Bollywood react I'm
here to talk to you about our sponsor
PayPal honey so if you're anything like
me you're already doing most of your
shopping online from groceries to food
to shoes but what if I told you there's
a little button that you can put at the
top of your screen that helps you get
sweet deals on the stuff that you're
already paying for well that's where
Honey comes into play honey
automatically searches for promo codes
so you don't have to it works for things
you're already buying on lots of sites
you're already shopping for and it's as
easy as this
it's super easy you just add it to your
browser and you start saving instantly
have you ever spent 10 minutes or more
just trying to find that promo code find
that promo code and then you don't end
up finding it and then you may not even
end up buying the product that you
originally went on there to get no more
of that
just click honey and the best part is
it's free but make sure you go to
joinhoney.com quarter crew so you can
start saving for free okay okay okay we
have an awesome episode coming up you
guys are in for a treat bye hey what's
up welcome back to another episode of
Bollywood react that's right we are
going back to India and we're checking
out all the new films that we've missed
the last few times that we looked at
this stuff because you guys have left so
many comments I couldn't help but say
it's Bali time
I was sitting in the office it was quiet
and ren was just reading comments and
just quietly I hear it's polytime
yeah of everything we've seen there's
three that stand out we have Tamil
nogaya AKA The Legend of Judo we have
rrr I think it's the golden standard
right now it's crazy it's over the top
it's also we've got a really authentic
genuine awesome story and obviously we
have saho which is the deep dark insane
Brothers the person who's Insanity meter
is completely empty or full depending on
yeah how that works um anyways so the
director of RR actually did a series
before called bahubali and there's a one
in two and he's actually looked at the
Catapult scene too which is amazing but
apparently this is amazing waterfall
scene for one so let's check it out
dude there's a water oh my God where's
the water going where is it coming from
there's like a small ocean up there oh
is she gonna who's jumping over
that
yeah oh he's making it there's no like
clever trick or anything he just
freaking does it oh CG leaves there oh
yeah
oh
tricked me oh that's the spirit of the
waterfall it's so weird how it's CG
cloth I mean it kind of works I only
realized it was CG cloth a few shots in
they're doing a decent job of matching
the CG cloth off of her hand to the rest
of her dress yeah like it's real up to
her wrists
hold up hold on time out is the water
going underneath him there when he's
hanging yeah he's really Compton it's
also oddly like high shutter speed this
is incredible yeah the Vista here whoa
whoa that's a sunset now it's night time
okay this is a very tall waterfall he's
still in a good mood though I mean it
takes people a few days to climb Half
Dome sometimes like you know they sleep
on the side of the cliff
oh dude this was the video
pause load
where are we
[Applause]
whoa dude this waterfall is so inspired
by Half Dome there's a moment in time in
the year when it looks like that
dude I too like to lift up my bows by
stomping on them just drive fired at
first oh oh Gopher Broke oh damn it's
not tied to anything except for his bow
and arrow oh my god wow this is pretty
sick actually
[Music]
yes
yes dude oh God I honestly just want to
keep watching the movie now yeah I do
get transported into it like I get swept
away in the world like it's having fun
but still also taking still seriously in
the right way yeah if you've seen
baahubali one or two let us know your
favorite scenes from it because I think
it could make an incredible one-off
episode just dedicated to this film so
you know the movie Ocean's 11 at the end
when they go this is what really
happened it goes into a montage and it
shows you all the stuff that really
happened so somebody was like what if we
just made the whole movie that and
that's uh that's thunibu
wow
he just walks out casually is he the
boss now
look at those Sparks and the real Sparks
how far they shoot out how big those
pops are they shoot six feet eight feet
out and then look at the Sparks behind
them when he starts shooting
like they're this big the reference is
right in front of you yeah in the movie
yeah there should be like five feet wide
[Music]
oh
yes dude oh no Trinity um
[Music]
that's so funny they have like a pad up
there yeah and they're painting out the
pad they put zero Shadow on that pillar
I mean they have already eroded them out
of the shot they can just take that
asset and shift it to the left a little
bit tint it black set it to 20 opacity a
little bit of blur it's like 70 really
sweet yeah and then 30 like why was the
mistake made there everyone knows what
they're doing you know it's well shot
there's some choreography there's some
practical and special effects and then
every once in a while it just gets like
they like they forgot to give that shot
some love
[Applause]
oh that's cool that's cool that's
wonderful I love that that's so
beautiful the chaos is so pretty CG
shots never look like that I feel like
anytime like a director has like a CG
shot like in the movie they're never
willing to just let us watch the physics
Sim how much of that was CG versus I
don't think any of that was CGS real
last shot I'm just saying like you
compare this like a shot that's like in
a Marvel movie they treat it as if it's
like they want to get away from it right
hot CG just cut away it's like no like
why is that shot there I wanted to see
these beautiful chunks of Rock and Smoke
flying around that's all I want to see I
like knocking over sand castes right I
just want to see it
oh here we go whoa wow these bullets are
traveling so we're back the bullets have
little rocket engines they're like the
little Rockets they're little Warhammer
bullets they're also like freaking like
50 cows they're like little chunks of
ChapSticks
oh
my God there's just like Freeze Frame
hits the first one that really was like
oof is the slo-mo muzzle flashes where
they didn't really quite know what to do
I love how they're motion blurred but
also like Frozen
like oh God you can see the sub stepping
in that motion blur too it almost looked
like scales I see the effects artist
crying out this time those muzzle
flashes happen they're frozen they're
literally Frozen they're like frozen or
like super low frame rate you know I can
see somebody be like well what does a
slow motion muzzle flash look like in a
slow motion muzzle flash is literally
just a slow explosion
oh it wasn't a dummy
oh he turned into me chunks
what is going on
that was some frame interpolation
they're pretty yucky that is some of the
most intense like interpolation
artifacting I've ever seen in a movie if
you film a scene normally you capture it
24 frames per second if you want to play
it in slow motion you would have had to
have actually captured it at a higher
frame rate like say 48 frames per second
100 frames a second a thousand frames
per second but then when you play those
frames back at 24 frames per second it
plays in slow motion but here look it
looks like they got a shot where they
wanted it to be in slow motion but they
didn't film it in slow motion so they
went hmm how do we fix this well they
used a handy dandy trick called Smooth
motion or frame warping frame
interpolation it's got a lot of
different terms basically what happens
is computer looks at one frame looks
with another frame and does Optical flow
AKA trying to guess what pixels went
where in the next frame it's basically
what happens in video codecs like h.264
codex but they're trying to take a shot
that has way too much of a jump between
frames so all you get is basically a
weird the baby morph effect as the
computer tries to figure out which parts
are going where and it just looks really
strange and does not at all look like
slow motion well I think it's also funny
because they did it after the shot was
completed it looks like they comp the
shot you're right and then they applied
it just the whole VFX shot if you look
at the flames in the legs you'll see it
like distorting the fire and the window
frames and all that stuff yeah this was
probably originally in the edit as a
much shorter shot and they decided that
oh this should be a little bit longer
but there wasn't much they could do
because the shot was already done
oh yeah oh
no impact
oh dang this guy just got walloped
[Music]
you imagine blocking your head like that
poking the top of your head it's so
anime just have wind blowing on people
when they have intense moments well it's
like we talk about anime aesthetic in
film right how you feel like it's the
next kind of like big thing in action
design is to kind of see like the anime
style of like visual storytelling
brought to life India's beating us
through that clearly like anime style
storytelling is like alive and well in
Indian Cinema yeah
[Music]
2.0 version 2.0 as if it couldn't get
better
I'm still a little confused did this
Eagle activate because he got a phone
it's made out of it's made out of phone
made out of he's completely made out of
phones it's a plot thing
I can tell that somebody like really
likes Transformers and like had these
Grand visions of like the street scene
oh it's like almost there like goes back
and forth from like these really hyper
real like GoPro shots or you know actual
stunts and cars flipping to like very
clearly animated
our boys back oh yeah look at this guy
healing his way in to save the day
on like a little trailer as they're
pulling them through that would be the
easiest
cars flying around him no those I mean
those look like real cars I think he's
being pulled I think that's like a
practically filmed shot I agree I feel
like he was probably holding on to
something and they cg'd out like his
hands and put gloves no he's got to be
standing on something probably he's
standing but also like holding like oh
yeah look at his legs are fully CG it's
like the bottom part of his legs and his
hands look like they're CG because you
don't want to stand on a piece of
cardboard going bad fast you'd lose your
balance so easily but he's probably
sitting on some sort of like bike seat
you know yeah she's like gripped in with
his legs
[Applause]
although that Indian Cinema their Heroes
just like a 55 year old man
gonna sleep all these falling people
there's a hundred people falling from
the air I'm Gonna Save all of them
are those people tumbling look at this
hero it's like Captain dissolution being
a superhero
yeah it kind of is I feel like that's
what he'd be doing also this like wide
shot we see him falling in slow motion
but the traffic's still moving at
regular speed
oh my God you're right
oh my God you're right yeah that's just
a real net though yeah it's a crazy
practical shot like once again that
looks so fun that first shot of them
falling down looks uncannon to me well I
think it's real because that shot where
they're all jumping off of it like
that's just a big real net there yeah so
I think they just have a big old net set
up and they roll some people down it and
that's as simple was it awesome separate
dude the net they look separate the net
animates because he's still lowering it
and it's probably a bit of a safety
concern having a bunch of people
tumbling down at the same time they
probably had to do each of these people
tumbling in different takes comp them
all together and then all these close-up
shots where they're not actually
tumbling they're just kind of rolling
and jumping off it's probably a bit of a
challenge trying to you know make all
that work together
this is the strangest superhero very
weird he is jogging he's designed to do
everything but run
they literally can do everything except
just run quickly I feel like this is
what like Mission Impossible like 15 is
gonna look like I want to see 85 year
old Tom Cruise running this fast up the
building
[Music]
oh my goodness wow
the weirdest face replacement whoa yes
whoa that's a cool shot was that was
that CG window break if he was all real
I think this is everything everything's
real actually the camera side of the
window and all that looks real but the
background also looks real too I mean
this could easily be done with real
background footage just tracked in I
doubt he's actually breaking through a
window even if it is harnessed up you
know 80 floors above the ground but
that's a nice compositing around those
motion blurred pieces of glass I'm just
saying there's like a 99 chance it's
just a window on a green screen and then
they just send a guy through it that's a
compositing nightmare I mean I think
it's real glass but the question is
what's behind the glass is it a green
screen oh yeah I agree because look at
how opaque this glass is it's fairly
easy to green screen out glass when it's
all frosted like that because you can
just desaturate any spill on it
I'm really confused how these shoes work
all
[Music]
the freaking splash
Splat it's magnets he's got his super
strong magnets getting that is that's
his ability yeah like it's crazy the CG
goes from being like janky to like
really solid all of a sudden like it
just goes back and forth the comping
inside the tank is wacky though it's
like bordering on Steven Seagal's
motorcycle helmet okay those shots are
Advanced shots yeah I feel like the
simulation team on this project yeah top
tier
some of these full CG shots are pretty
great yeah like that's a CG model of the
dude
oh they are Heelys they are healing wait
you lead out of a cyber nanobot eagle
oh my God
so he escaped the tank and he's opening
the gas tank of the tank and he's he's
grinding
the gas tank wow yeah it turns out you
think they didn't think it out turns out
I didn't think it out yeah so I guess
the plot of this is that cell phones and
like evil telecom companies were like
screwing up birds with radiation from
their cell phone towers and so like this
one guy who loves Birds kills himself
over how sad he is that the birds are
dying and then that evil bird spirit
that we saw combines with him and turns
him into this guy
all the cell phone towers right next to
each other in the stadium
5G baby oh
[Laughter]
yeah
you ride that Sony FX1 into the battle
ride that cable cam do these phones the
phones I this I like whoa that's cool
okay
wow magnetic mode
oh is this again it's just this again
but look how much better it looks this
is basically like a YouTube clickbait
thumbnail as a movie dude look at this
guy just killing people on the stands
nah nah the guns are pointed down more
[Applause]
may be hitting people yeah oh dude it
shot the camera wait hold on the camera
same shot wait Bonk Bonk there it is
wait no no which one's gonna hit the
camera that one
shot
there it is a bird is back this stuff
looks great
oh the ball form 1.0 is back it's a
really crazy 3D model
oh my God everyone's dead now
Ron every
where
oh he's like I can't touch it it's too
prickly
there's literally people there
like a little too far into the cartoon
realm really
oh my goodness that's a great photo scan
when you don't have to optimize your
geometry I Gotta Give Them points for
the the creativity oh yeah look at all
that aluminum getting magnetized
everything made out of metal the spoons
the watches the zippers off your pants
he's got cool oh car abs
oh my god oh did he just kneel him we
just got agent Smith this is very high
concept uh wow
[Laughter]
oh the real birds are coming
[Applause]
3.0 yes I love it look how cool he is
he's like a Saturday morning TV show
host
Ant-Man doesn't have on this
oh my gods they are phones to fight the
phones they must become phones explode
oh he's freaking Samsung
all the microbots go to Samsung mode and
they freaking burst
okay let's see how this wraps up though
[Music]
yeah turn on that microwave burst that
guy oh he's toast
boom boom
everyone wins the end boom boom
[Music]
man every time we watch these Bollywood
Clips there's so much intensity and
energy that I like I'm just drained the
rest of the day that waterfall stain
makes me feel like I just climb a mental
waterfall It's Gonna Take Me days to
recover it's really important you
subscribe right now because when we do
that baahubali episode you're not going
to want to miss it thanks for watching
everyone see you next week